hi everybody welcome to another tango
technique class at home
i hope you are all doing fine so today
is going to be about lapis
luckily philippines love is everything
about lapis
lapis is spanish for pencil
and the idea is that your free leg
becomes like a pencil
and the big toe is the point of that
pencil
and you use it to draw on the floor
typically you draw circles
the circles can be from front to back or
from back to front in this class we will
focus
on from the back yeah so when you say
pencil it doesn't refer so much to how
your
free leg is supposed to look like lapid
refers more to the actual drawing on the
floor
so when you draw these circles that's
actually what you call lapis the drawing
okay so today we will start with a
warm-up
then we will do a preparation exercise
for changing weight during latitudes
which will be
important for later and then we will do
a set of exercises in which we will
combine latif
with pivot counter clockwise and
clockwise
and crosses back to find
very interesting possibilities like we
usually do okay
and then we will repeat this set of
exercises a second time
but this time using a double labyrinth
which looks like this it's a small lapis
followed by a big lapis which is a very
beautiful alarm that the man can do okay
so
let's start with the wall now okay warm
up so today
is going to be quite similar to the
usual program but a little bit different
because we're going to combine
exercises together movements together
okay
so we start with feet together legs
together
and take a few seconds to just breathe
deeply
relax let the weight of your body come
down to the floor
and feel stable and then for the first
one we will combine
circles with the shoulders and circles
with the
arms okay so remember when you do the
circle with the shoulder
don't use the elbows keep the arms
relaxed and
when you do the circle with the arms
remember to keep your elbows straight
and to open the chest yeah so one circle
with shoulders and one circle with arms
and then we will do eight
okay so let's start one
shoulder and arm
two and two
three and three
four and four
five and five
six and six
seven and seven
eight and eight okay
very good for the next one we will keep
our legs
closed like this and then we will
combine two exercises
the first one will be the one where we
cross our fingers
we turn our palms to the floor we
stretch the elbows and then we raise our
hands above our head
to stretch the torso and from here we
will drop
only one arm like this only one
the other stays up and then from here we
go into this exercise where we touch our
knee
and we stretch the side of the torso
yeah and then we use the handle is up to
return back to the vertical
and drop the arm and then we will repeat
from the beginning
raising the hands and then here we will
drop
the other arm yeah and then we will
stretch
the other side of the torso then back to
vertical
drop the arm and start from the
beginning okay so we will do it
four times okay let's start so cross
fingers turn
palms stretch elbows raise hands
stretch and then drop one arm
go down stretch aside
go up and down this was one
okay raise hands
stretch drop the other arm
and then go down and
up drop the arm this was one to the
other side so two
raise hands stretch
drop one arm go down
stretch go up
and cross fingers go up
stretch drop the other arm
go down stretch
go up and lower the arm two
now this is the third cross fingers
raise
hands stretch drop one arm
go to the side stretch the side
go up lower the arm
and three to the other side raise the
hands
stretch drop the other arm
go to the side stretch the side
go up lower down and the last one
cross fingers raise hands
stretch draw one arm
then go to the side stretch the side
go up a lower arm and
the last one to the other side raise the
hands stretch
both arms then drop the other arm
down stretch the side
and go up and down
okay now for the next one we will open
the legs
a bit wider than the shoulders we will
bend the knees a little bit
and then we will do this rotation of the
torso
we will just do eight just by themselves
okay
like we do in the normal warm up so
eight times
left and right very relaxed try to reach
the limit
okay so one and
two and three and four
and five and six and
seven and eight okay remember not to
move the hip
only the torso then we will stretch
the legs okay the knees and then we'll
place
our hands behind the head usually here
we bend and we go down like this
on the center between the legs yeah so
we will do this
but then the next one we will rotate the
torso like this
without moving the hips and then we will
lower the torso
over one leg yeah
like this and then we will return
up we will rotate the torso to the other
side
and then we will go down on the other
leg like this
yeah this one and then we will go up
and then again center yeah center
up one leg up the other leg
up this is one and we will do four okay
so we start with the center
hands behind the head and let's start
one
on the center bounce bounce
bounce up
one on one leg bounce
bounce bounce up
one on the other bounce
two on the center bounce
bounce bounce up
two on one leg
back down bounce
up two on the other leg
bounce bounce bounce
up three on the center
up three on one leg
bounce bounce bounce
up three on the other leg
up four on the center
bounce bounce bounce and up
four on one leg pull down bounce
bounce bounce and up
four on the other leg go down
bounce bounce bounce and
up okay good now the next one
we keep the legs like they are open and
straight
okay and then we will do the rotation
with our hips this one we will do by
itself
yeah because it's not worth to combine
it with other things
so we will go back and then we will
rotate the hip
remember to keep your legs straight at
all times
to keep your heels on the floor at all
times
and to keep your head in one position
and only move the hip
in a wide circle okay so we will do
eight
on one direction and then eight on the
other direction
so we start back and then we go to
the right or to to this side if you are
doing it in a mirror don't worry about
left or right just copy what i do
okay so one
two and three
and four
now change direction one
on okay now for the last one
we will join our legs so there is no
space between them
and usually what we do is we bend our
knees we relax our knees and we bounce
three times
down bounce bounce then we go up
and then we go on the toes so that we
can lift
our heels and we hold this position for
three seconds
so what we are going to do here when you
are up is we're going to shift
our weight to one leg and we're going to
try
to lift the other foot like this
and then join it and then go down and
bounce three times
then we will go up again on our toes
we will shift our way to the other foot
and we will try briefly to lift the
other leg
yeah and then join and then down yeah
so each time one leg will do it four
times with each time
with each leg yeah and this is of course
obviously about balance yeah about
strengthening your legs and working on
your core
and improving your balance so let's
start if you want you can grab your hips
yeah and then we start with bouncing one
bounce bounce bounce stretch
go up shift the weight to one foot
lift and join
balance bounce bounce go
up shift to your foot
lift and join
two balance bounce
go up shift to one foot
lift the foot joint
bunks bounce bounce go up
shift the weight to the other foot
lift and down
three bounce bounce bounce
up go to one foot
lift and join
bounce bounce bounce go
up lift
and join and then again bounce
down spawns go up
lift one foot stay there
join and bounce bounce bounce
go up shift
lift stay there stay there stay there
then join and down okay
good so this was a warm up now we are
ready to work and let's go to the first
exercise okay the first exercise we're
going to do
is in order to improve the smoothness
of our changes of weight yeah so the
exercise goes like this
uh you start with your weight on one leg
the free leg is behind you with the toes
pointing down
and then you move your free leg slowly
towards a cross back yeah and the moment
that you reach the zero position you
change the weight very fast so that you
can continue
the movement on the other leg until then
until you are front like this and then
from here you do the opposite
you close your leg and then you the
moment you reach the zero position
you make the change of weight very fast
very quickly
so that the movement continues and
broken
on the other leg to this position to the
back position okay
so now in order to do this uh well
there is an idea that needs to be clear
uh whenever you change weight in tango
the change of weight is instantaneous
there is no moment
where your weight is on both feet like
this because the minute this happens you
kill the lungs you kill the flow
so you have to imagine that the way the
way it works in tango
is like a light switch yeah when you
have a light switch it can be on
the light is on or it can be off and the
light is off but it doesn't make sense
for the light switch to be in the middle
like the light is on and off at the same
time that doesn't make sense
so um in tango the weight is the same
your weight is either on one foot or on
the other foot
but never on both so when you transfer
the weight from one foot to the other
the weight change
has to be like a switch instantaneous
and this has the advantage that it
allows you
to take movements through the change of
weight
in a very fluid way so i'm going to show
you again
yeah you start like this and then you
move the way
the leg and then you try to make this
change of weight
as fast as you can so that you have
an unbroken movement okay and one last
thing
this is not about moving your legs very
fast
because some people do like this bump
and then they finish the movement very
quickly now
the movement has to be slow the movement
of the leg has to be slow
and only the change of weight has to be
very quick
so that you don't notice any break in
the movement
from one leg to the other okay there are
guys who i have seen that can do this
extremely well
you don't see any cut in the movement i
am not
that good but at least i can describe
what you should aim for
and i can show you the best i can okay
so
we will do it with the metronome eight
times to each side
as always 58 ppm
and two bits per bar okay
so let's do this side first
put your weight on one leg the three leg
is behind you toes pointing down
remember your hip your torso thumb and
breaks
and then let's start eight times
one one
and two two
three three
four four
five guys
six six
seven seven
eight eight
okay try really to work on this illusion
that the movement doesn't stop from one
leg to the other
okay let's do the other side so put your
weight on the other leg
and then your feeling is behind toes
toes pointing down
and then let's do it eight times to this
side
and one one
two two
three three
four four
five five
six six
seven seven
eight eight
okay good so this was the first exercise
this will be
important for our combinations with
lapis which will
we'll start right now okay so let's do
it okay the first exercise with lap
is going to be very simple it goes like
this you start in zero position
you change your weight to one leg and
then with the other leg you do
eight lap effects from front to back
like this when you finish the eight
graphics
you finish the last lapis in a cross
back and then you change the weight and
you continue
with eight laptops with the other leg
yeah
when you finish the elapses we repeat
the whole thing again so you finish with
a crossbar
and then you do again eight lapras with
the first leg
you cross back and then eight laptops
with the other leg
and that's it okay now for the technique
of the exercise
so the details are like this first i
recommend you to
relax your knees especially the standing
leg
and bend the knee a little bit because
this will give you more stability
yeah then the lucky with the free leg
starts
front yeah some people especially when
they dance fast
they take a shortcut and they start the
lap it very quickly to the side
don't do that start the lapis always
to the front yeah projecting the leg and
stretching the foot then when you open
the leg
to the side to start with make sure that
you are using
only the hip yeah only this joint
don't move anything else don't move the
torso to compensate what the leg is
doing
don't move the heat don't move anything
just
rotate the head of the femur inside the
hip socket
and then you trace 180 degree arc on the
floor
until you finish on the back position
that means and now i'm going to show you
from behind
when you are here on the back position
be careful with your foot with the toes
of your foot don't do this
yeah make sure that you have the big toe
on the floor and then you let your heel
fall a little bit to the inside
yeah then here your leg should still be
straight
then you relax the knee yeah you're
relaxing
here so that you can pass the foot
through zero position
and then start with the next slide yeah
and the next lapis of course starts
flat yeah like this then
when you change the weight in the cross
remember the exercise we did before i'll
show you from profile
so you're doing the last lap here and
now you're going to cross
back so make the change of weight as
instantaneous as you can
so that you give the illusion of an
unbroken movement from one lapis to the
other lap
with the other leg so that you don't
break the flow okay
that's the goal okay so we will do this
together
and i will show you from the back so you
can follow me
and we will do it with a method yeah
now when you finish the eight laps the
egg lamp is going to be a little bit
faster
so that we maintain the one of the
metronome
going forward with the food yeah okay
so let's start just follow
my speed
[Music]
four
on
[Music]
six and
seven and
eight and one
and
i
okay so that's the exercise
of course if you want you can do this as
long as you
want changing uh weight every eight
lapis
okay so let's go to the next exercise
okay the next exercise is going to be
very similar
but we are going to change weight after
each laughing
so we do one lapid we cross back and
then we change weight
and we do the lapping with the other leg
like this so we will
change weight continuously yeah now for
the technique
it's the same yeah try especially now
to make the change of weight smoothly
so that the movement continues from one
leg to the next and here what happens
sometimes
is that we do a little jump
like this yeah you should avoid that
yeah because any movement like this that
you
do it's not only that it looks bad it's
that your partner will feel it you will
feel this vibration there and it will
distract her
okay so or him so when you do the change
just make sure that you don't move
anything
on the embrace yeah on the torso
yeah that is completely smooth and you
keep it on your feet
okay so let's do it um 16 times with
each leg
okay with the metronome
okay so get ready zero position
another lapis will be a little bit
faster because
we need to change weight after each one
yeah okay
so get ready we start with right away
and one
one two
two three
three four
four five
five six six
seven seven
eight eight and eight more
one one
two two
three three
four four
bye five
six six
seven seven
eight
[Music]
okay good
when you do the crossback try to really
close it in zero position because
otherwise
in each cross you will be going back
going back so try to stay
during the whole exercise in one place
okay
so now on the next exercises we are
going to
introduce pivots okay let's go for it
okay in this exercise we will combine
latif
with pivot of the standing leg yeah and
the structure of the exercise is like
this
you will do one lapid and after the
lapid is finished
you will do a 90 degrees pivot following
the direction of the lattice so if you
start with the right leg for example
the lattice is to the right then at the
end of the lapid
the pivot will be 90 degrees also to the
right
okay always following the direction of
the
lucky yeah and uh we will do
eight lapis yeah so one
pivot two people and so on and on the
eighth flap
yeah you won't pass the foot anymore
from zero position
you will cross it behind and then you
will change the weight
you will put the other leg forward and
then
you will continue doing eight more lapis
with the other leg
and of course because now is the left
leg it's the other leg the pivot will be
90 degrees
to the left yeah so the people now
follows the direction
of the new lapis okay now how does this
work
with the time with the beats
so it will be like this um the lapis
will always take four beats yeah so
one two one two on the one
on the first one the foot is front
you point the foot forward on the two
the lapit is in progress the leg is more
or less
on your side okay on the three you
finish the lapis the leg is behind and
the toes are pointed down
okay and on the four you pass the foot
through
zero yeah so it's one
two three four or one
two one two you have four beats one
two one two front
side back zero front
side back zero now
um where do you put the pivot in time
well it's like this on the first
three beats one two three you don't do
anything
yeah on the four when the foot
the free foot is on zero then you turn
the torso
90 degrees towards the direction of the
free leg
yeah away from the standing leg so
fourth
and then when you are here between the
four
and the next one on the end that's when
you pivot
and then you start on the next one the
new pin
yeah then you lock it so it's like
slowly it's
like it's one two
three four
one two three
four one two
three four yeah front
side back torsion zero position pivot
front side okay so the pivot
happens at the end between the four and
then
one of the next lapis okay
now a few tips about the technique how
to do this correctly so
the first thing when you are doing the
lapis
uh bend the standing leg quite a lot
yeah don't be afraid to bend the knee
and go
down with your torso with your hip yeah
so that you feel closer to the floor and
this will help your balance yeah
you're closer to the floor and you have
a very stable basis
yeah so the standing leg is bent the
second thing that i recommend
when you put your arms in embrace tumble
brace like this
or like this for the woman try to hold
your arms
low yeah because if you do the exercise
with the arms too high
like this you will feel a bit
top heavy yeah sometimes when we
are doing technique exercises and we are
very concentrated
we tend to stress a little bit and one
effect of this is that the arms start
going up so
try to find that tendency and hold your
arms low
close to your center yeah below the
chest
because this position will also
contribute
to the feeling of being low close to the
floor
yeah and this will help your balance
yeah
like this and the third tip and very
important one
because now we are using a very slow
tempo yeah
usually when you use these lapis in the
minomura when you go dancing
usually you will do it faster but now
that we are doing it so slow
try not to mix the movements yeah
try that your movements don't overlap
for example
on the first three beats one two one
move only the leg nothing else until the
leg is back
is behind don't move anything don't
worry about pivots
don't worry about torsion when the foot
is on zero position then you move the
torso 90 degrees to the left
to the direction of the um standing leg
yeah and then when the torso is
completely turned
and not before then you turn the hip
yeah try not to overlap
the torsion of the upper body with the
hip
because this will have a negative impact
on your balance
try to really separate the movements
only the leg
only the torso only the hip
yeah and the pivot okay
so as i said before we do eight
pivots to one side yeah i will start
from the back so you can follow me our
sides are the same
but then because i'm using pivots you
will see the exercise from every
direction
yeah then after the eighth pivot
we will close back in a
back cross so we can change the leg and
then we will do
eight pivots on the other direction then
we will cross back again
and we will do eight more with the first
leg
cross back eight more with the second
okay and i will start with the right
good
so let's leave with the metronome yeah
slowly
my explanation was long so this switched
off
okay so 58 bpm as always
and each lapis is four beats one
two one two pivot
one two one two
people okay so let's do it together
fit in zero position remember the tips
about the posture
arms relaxed and low bend your standing
leg
we start with the right and the pivot
goes to the right
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
five one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
across about one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
cross one one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay good
okay so let's go to the next exercise
okay this exercise will be very similar
to the one which is the
the difference will be that after you do
the lapif the pivot will go away
from the free leg so for example if you
start the exercise with the right leg
and your lap of course goes to the right
at the end of the lap if the pivot will
go to the left
yeah away from the free leg
yeah in the opposite direction luck is
to one side
people to the other side okay now
the time with the beat is exactly the
same
on the one you start the lapis you point
your foot forward
on the two your three leg is on the side
yeah on the three the three leg is
behind with the toes pointed down
and then on the four the foot passes
through zero position
and at the same time the torso turns
away from the free leg yeah away from
the freeway
and then between the four and the next
one on the end
that's when you peel four times one
yeah so if i do it very slowly counting
the weights it will be like it's
one two three
four and one two
three four and one
two three four
and one yeah okay now
the technical tips are the same yeah
bend your standing knee lower the arms
all of this is for balance and i cannot
stress enough the importance
to separate your movements yeah to not
overlap them so when you do the lapis
you only move the leg
when you pass through zero you only turn
the torso
and when the torso is completely turned
then you move the heel
you don't mix the movements and then
the reason to do it like this is not
only that
um you will focus on doing the exercise
clean
but it also allows you now that we are
using
a slow tempo it allows you to focus on
one technical problem
at a time yeah so when you start the
exercise you only have to worry
about the length nothing else only the
leg
yeah then when you reach this point you
only have to worry about the torso
and nothing else not even the pivot yeah
and then
when you have dealt with your torso now
you only have to worry
about pressing the floor down with your
standing leg
and twisting the hip for the people yeah
so it's one
problem at a time you deal with your leg
then you deal with your torso and then
you deal with your hip
yeah one thing at the time because then
this will build
a habit if you practice consistently and
when you do it
faster then you will have this cleanness
because you have solved
one technical problem at a time okay and
one last tip that i have
is try that your free leg
is always moving always moving
there is not one moment where the leg is
uh
still the free leg is still so that
means that you have to
uh the speed of your leg yeah
so that there is no moment where you
have to wait for example if your lap is
too fast
then you will have to wait with the leg
back
until the next bit comes and then you
can close and do the pivot
yeah or if you do the lapis and you
close your foot too early
then you have to wait until you pivot
and the left hand continue moving
so try to avoid that try to avoid these
stalks that's why i move the
leg very slowly one two
especially after you your leg is back
here when you pass through zero and you
do the pivot try
that the leg is all moving yeah
always moving three four
one yeah work on this because
then your free leg will look like it's
drawing on the floor
and that's a very important quality in
tango
dancing tango means among other things
drawing
on the floor with your free leg yeah
so when you draw you don't want to stop
yeah you want to keep the drawing
always in movement okay so let's do it
together
eight times then cross back like we did
before
then it comes with the other leg another
crossbar and then
it comes with the first leg close back
eight times a little
bit okay so let's do it together
zero position go down
relax the arms and then we start with
the right leg the left
is to the right and the pivot will be to
the left okay
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
people close one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
[Music]
eight
it was crossbar one
[Music]
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight p
of crossbar one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great ah let's go to the next exercise
okay in this exercise we are going to do
lapis with
both legs yeah flapping with one leg
then we will cross behind we will switch
the legs
and then we will do the lapping with the
other leg yeah so one lap
with each leg and cross back to switch
between legs now that's the idea of the
exercise
of course we will combine these with
pivots and it will work like this look
when you for example start with right
leg you the first lap is to the right
the first pivot goes following
the direction of the laplace so your
laplace to the right the pivot is to the
right as well
but then when you switch legs and you do
the second lapping
the pivot the second pivot will go
against
the lapis so away from the free leg like
this
yeah and then you switch legs and then
again first lapis
you turn in the direction of the lucky
second lapis you pivot against the
direction of the life
so the effect is that you are always
turning to the same side
yeah to the right to the right to right
okay that's the first thing the second
thing
is that the two lapis with each leg one
have the same speed
so when you do the first slapping it
will be a slow lap if it will take
four beats like we have been doing one
two
three four yeah and then when you switch
the leg for the second lobby the second
update will be
half the time so two bits only one
two yeah so when you start with the
first leg
is four bits one two three
four when you do the second lap it is
only one
two okay and then you cross back that's
the second
thing and this change of speed will give
the exercise a
nice feeling of dynamic because you are
switching between
a slow movement and then a fast movement
yeah so with the teeth it works like
this
you start on the one with the first leg
yeah
and this lapis takes four beats so
on the one year front on the two-year
side
on the three you are back on the fourth
you turn the torso to the pivot
in the direction of the free leg yeah
and then on the end you pivot and you
cross back
then on the one you point the for
the foot front of the second leg and on
the two
you are already back and turning the
torso so it's faster
yeah one two and on the end
between the two and the one then you
pivot and you change the leg
yeah so it will be like this slowly
one two three
four and one two
and one two okay
that's the idea then the last thing
sorry the explanation is long but the
exercise is a bit complex uh we will do
this
eight times yeah to one side and then we
will use a transition
to change the direction of the exercise
and do it to the other side and the
transition is like this
imagine that you are doing the last
lapis with the right leg to the right
yeah and it's a slow one one two
three four and you change the leg and
now you do the last
fast slapping with the left one
two so here you don't cross back anymore
you pass the foot through zero yeah
because then you can use the same leg
to start the next slow lapping to the
other side to the left
yeah so the last ocho
and the transition looks like this one
two three four
and one two zero
one two three
four and one two and then you start
turning
always to the left yeah eight times two
so we will do it eight times to the
right then transition eight times to the
left
and then again we'll repeat the whole
thing transition it turns to right
transition items to left
okay good so let's do it together
with the metronome
and remember all the technical tips here
bend the legs
lower the arms straight posture
yeah and separate the movements you have
one movement at a time okay zero
position
bend the legs and locks the arms and we
start with the
right leg and the left goes to the right
one
one two
two three
three four
four five
five six
six seven
seven eight
eight transition one
one two
two three
three four
four five
five six
six seven
seven eight
eight transition one
[Music]
one two
two three
three four
four five five
six
six seven
seven eight
eight transition one
one two
two three
three four
4 5
5 6
six seven
seven eight
eight
okay this was long one
okay great let's go to the next exercise
okay in this exercise we'll do the
opposite of what we did on the previous
one
in terms of the direction of the pivots
so for example if you start the
exercise with your right leg and the
first sloppy
goes to the right the first pivot is
going to go to the left
so away from the free leg away from the
left
yeah and then on the second luggage that
you know
that you do with the left the pivot will
be also
to the left so you will follow the
direction
of the light yeah so it's the opposite
of before
lapping with right pivot away from
the free leg change leg
lock it with left pivot towards the
lapis
and change there yeah we will keep the
relative speeds
of the lapis that we used in the
previous exercise so
the first flappit is always going to be
slow just like before
slow lapping in four beats yeah
then people change weight and then fast
that with
in two weeks and then change way yeah
so the exercise feels different although
it's very similar the feeling in the
body is different because
before the slow lapis was the one where
ha that had the people going in the same
direction
yeah and the first habit was the one in
which we go against the land
yeah but now
the slovak is the one that
has the pivot going against the lobby
so it gives us a lot of time for this
counter
torsion and then the fast lapid is the
one that has the pivot going in the same
direction
yeah so the feeling is a bit different
okay
the technique is the same and the
transition
also is the same so when you do the
eighth
lapis the last one like this yeah for
example you are doing the slow one
and then you pivot away from it when you
do the fast slapping
at the end you don't cross back you pass
through zero
and then you can use the same leg to do
the slow lapis
on the other leg and then you pivot
against it
and then you're going to do the whole
thing to the other direction
okay i hope you can follow the
explanation in any case i'll do it now
with you eight times to one direction
then we will use the transition eight
times to the other direction and i will
repeat again the whole thing
it comes first direction transition
three times second direction
okay so let's do it together
with a metronome
okay
so get ready in zero position
bend the knees so you have a good bases
relax the arms
hold your arms close to your center and
we start with the right leg
the first slapping goes to the left to
the right obviously
and then the pivot will go against to
the left
okay let's do it together
one
one two
[Music]
two three
three four
four five
five six
six seven
seven eight
eight transition one
one two
two three
three four
four five
five six
six seven
seven eight
eight transition one
one two
two three
three four
four five
five six
six seven
seven eight
eight transition one
one two
two three
three four
four five
five six
six seven
seven eight
eight up
okay great
so don't forget the technical tips about
separating the movements
and one uh another tip that i would like
to give you is that
because when the exercise gets
complicated like this with lots of
structure and
changes of direction to remember the
technique can suffer
so my tip is to keep balance yeah and to
avoid
um losing it when you are finishing a
lapis
yeah the slow or the fast one doesn't
matter
and you are crossing back focus all your
attention
after the pivot into the placement
of the free foot that is going to become
the standing foot you want to step with
the foot
under your head and the foot is going to
be pointed
in the new direction 90 degrees from the
old one yeah so let's say
you are finishing this lapis one two
one focus on this placement because this
will give you the security
to start the new movement yeah now you
do the next step is
when the leg is behind you turn 90
degrees now
focus on the placement of this foot
yeah one two three
four one yeah place it straight
looking in the direction of the new
um step yeah focus on that
and that will also help you to maintain
balance when you are switching legs
which is a delicate
movement okay so let's go to the next
exercise
okay in this exercise we're going to use
this little circle with the foot that i
told you about in the beginning of the
video
so how does this work well this is
a little circle that you do with the
foot in front of you
yeah it's very small and the way to do
it right
technically is like this you need to
combine
two small movements with the knee and
with the hip i show you from the side
because it's easier to see
the first movement that you have to use
is a very small movement with the knee
yeah front and back like this front and
back
so you have to relax the leg yeah make
sure it's relaxed
and then just move the knee like this
it's very tiny
okay the second movement i'll show you
from the front
is from the hip and it's like this
it moves the leg sideways left and right
yeah like this so when you combine the
movement of the knee and the movement of
the hip
you have the circle yeah the circle
is the result of a movement front and
back
with the knee and a movement left and
right
with the hip yeah if you prefer you can
just
imagine that you want to draw a circle
with a foot on the floor that's
that's easier yeah but mechanically with
the leg that's how it works if you want
to know
okay so how do we use this little
movement
well usually you do it only once yeah
you do it only once
and then you connect it with a lavish
yeah
you do a little circle to the outside
all usually it's always to the outside
it's very rare
that somebody does the circle to the
inside yeah usually it's through the
outside
outside and then connect it with the
lavish and the way you do that is that
after the circle
you stretch the knee and you lock it
yeah
and then you move you do the lapping
which is only from the hip
yeah only from the hip without the knee
so you relax the knee
and then you move the leg from the hip
yeah time wise with a bit it works like
this
we still want to start the big lobby
from the one that means that the circle
has to be before the one
on the end and one so we go
and one yeah and the lapid
will be slow so four beats one
on the front two on the side three on
the back
and four on zero position passing
through zero position without stopping
yeah and one two
three four and one
two three four and one
and so on yeah and one last technical
tip about this
is that because the circle is
small and fast and the lattice
afterwards
is big and slower this gives you a great
opportunity to practice your dynamic
yeah because you are changing from one
movement that is the opposite of the
other quick and small
big and slow okay so
that means don't get too excited with
the first circle
yeah because sometimes in the stress of
the
movement people do the circle too big
yeah
and then it looks like you're actually
trying to do two lap effects
it looks like this yeah big circle and
then big lovely
looks like two lapids that are very
stressed
so try to find the dynamic yeah try to
exaggerate
the difference between the two movements
and the first circle
you look very tiny and very fast yeah
pull from the knee and then the big
lapith
you will slowly and giving you time yeah
one two three
four and one two three
four quick slow yeah so we will do
eight times this with one leg no pivots
because we want to concentrate on the
little circle
yeah so always in one direction i will
do it
from the back so you can follow my left
and my right but i wanted to show you
from the front because from the back
you you won't be able to see this circle
so well yeah
and then after the eighth lap yeah
on the four three four we cross back
yeah four and one yeah so
after the cross on the fourth we will do
the little circle right away
four and one two three yeah
so be careful with that transition okay
so let's sleep together
eight times with one leg cross back it
comes with the other leg
cross back and then repeat the whole
thing eight times close eight times
okay so let's do it together with the
metronome
58 bpm
okay let's do it together to your
position
we start with the right leg okay and
lock is of course also right
and one
[Music]
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
[Music]
eight
okay
great yeah try to uh really relax the
leg
and when you do the little circle in
front of you try to use the upper
leg as little as possible try that the
movement comes mostly
i mean the whole leg will move but the
idea is that you are
drawing from as low as possible from the
knee
with the lower leg yeah that's the idea
okay
so now we go to the last exercise okay
in this last exercise we will do what we
did in the previous one but we will
combine it with
pivots because pivots always make
everything more interesting
yeah so it will be like this you start
with the right leg and on the end before
the one
you do the little circle in front of you
and
one two and then you do the lapid which
is a slow one yeah so four beats
on the one you're in front on the two
yard on the side
on the three you are behind yeah then on
the four
when the free foot is passing through
zero that's
where you turn the torso to the right so
in the direction of the lobby towards
your free leg
yeah and then on the end after the four
between the four and the next one that's
when you
pivot and do a little circle again
and one yeah so the last part
of the exercise is in slow motion
and one two
three four and one
two three four
and one yeah so right after the pivot
you do the little circle as a
continuation of the pivot
yeah pivot and one yeah
this adornment this little lapis
actually comes very natural after a
pivot
because it follows the same direction of
the build
okay good so as before
we will do it eight times to one side
yeah
and then after the eighth pivot we will
cross back
so the last pivot will look like this
and
one two three
four and one yeah so after the cross
right after the cross you do the little
circle
and then on the one you do the lapis
with the other leg and then you do the
whole thing
to the other side eight times then we
cross back again
and then we wait eight more times with
the first leg
and then cross back eight more times
with the left leg
okay so let's do it together
with the metronome
and now i'll start from behind so
you can do it with me with the same size
but because we are using a pivot you
will be able to see the exercise from
every side okay so
let's do it
okay so zero position prepare
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
close one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
plus one
two
three
four
five
[Applause]
six
seven
[Music]
eight
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay great
so that was the last exercise and
although this class is mainly for the
man this material is very useful for the
repertoire of the man
women can also benefit from these
exercises with luckiest and changes of
weight
how well for example when the man leads
you
a calisthenic yeah so let's say you are
maybe finishing another bag and then
you're on one foot and the man lifts you
and then he starts walking around you
yeah in a circle and you turn with him
so you can do lots of love effects
and even change of weight yeah
meanwhile he's walking around you so
laggy face
and changes of leg with the lapic is a
great adornment for the woman
during a calicita so these exercises
will also help you
okay so thank you very much for watching
and practice practice practice and i
will see you on the next video